[Music]
we're gonna be doing a clip show of the
office with some holiday specials but
we're also gonna be playing a little
Yankee Swap of our own Gillian play that
first clip Brian dumped whoa video iPod
oh wow jeez
so we really got carried away with this
spirit of Christmas that was me I got
carried away a disparity wasn't there a
$20 limit on the gift this is 400 bucks
you don't know that
yeah you left the price tag off I did
yeah why oh shoot Wow
okay well who cares doesn't matter what
I spent what matters is it Christmas is
fun right Michael oh hey for me what is
I knitted it for you an oven mitt
so Phyllis is basically saying hey
Michael I know you did a lot to help the
office this year but I only care about
you a homemade oven mitts worth
I gave right an iPod um should we just
keep opening up the presents we don't do
anything until Michael gives us further
instructions
I got it we are going to turn Secret
Santa into Yankee Swap what is Yankee
Swap one person chooses a gift
the next person can either choose a gift
or steal that person's gift if your gift
gets stolen then you can steal someone
else's gift or choose a new gift I
thought that was called nasty Christmas
Christmas party and we're gonna play a
little nasty Christmas of our own right
now so they had a $20 gift limit we have
a $10 gift I think a lot of us went to
the pharmacy downstairs a video iPod is
$10 so to get things started
Jordan why don't you go first since
yours you just pick one of these four
gifts okay
what was everyone hoping for this
holiday season
oh I know what's these funny is I want
my friends and family to be happy
pho tale for your iPhone that's not a
current iPhone at all it's it's like an
old iPhone with literally an accessory
for a video iPod and you can preview
it's been touched for years there's some
dust on this also it is Jillian took off
the price tag but it was $9.99 for this
I can I can jelly and play that next
clip
what is this
happy holidays Dwight but do not open it
until Christmas you're so pathetic how
long did this take you three hours five
minutes actually I am a black belt in
gift wrapping yeah no such thing they
don't give out black belts for things
that are stupid well I hope it was worth
it cuz I'm gonna take it apart in about
five minutes I think I'll take a little
bit longer than that
really if I can skin a mule deer in less
than 10 minutes I ought to be able to
cut my Natasha you're okay so I don't
want this piece of trash okay so I think
I think that's a candle I don't want
that how do you know that I'm just
kidding I'm trying to get a vibe okay
this feels like multiple items so maybe
yes I say quantity over quality okay
look okay this may be I think is an old
timey map treasure map psych it is the
hell is this and it's colorful this is
great okay hell yeah okay closest to
like somebody board and give them it's
so delightful oh oh go with the head
scratcher maybe a razor
[Laughter]
the exits check executive you guys it's
Tara wait Natasha do you think those
things can do this go ahead play that
next clip
I'm sorry I had no idea no it's it's
okay okay oh my god oh my god no never
okay this is it in the end the greatest
snowball isn't a snowball at all it's
fear Merry Christmas
have you guys ever been in a snowball
fight yeah okay we all take a like
maybe one of the keys of Poconos and one
of my dad's friends it was like a
collegiate level picture oh it was my
dad five kids in his friend and he was
picking us off that kind of sass oh it
was and what would I try to jump over
one snowball to hit me in the foot and I
legitimately on the roof of my apartment
in college and we were throwing
snowballs at passer buys and it was like
fun his bro in college whatever and it
was like laughing and then I saw someone
like very far away and I was like I'm
gonna try and hit that person and I
picked up a snowball and like it was
more of like an ice ball and then I
threw it and I was like no way it's
hitting her because I story in slow
motion saw the snowball homed in on her
face and it's like it was going for the
side of her head and then she turns the
shock
I don't think I'm going to jail so I ran
downstairs and I hid in my apartment for
the rest of the night let's keep this
Yankee Swap moving along Chris you're up
you can steal one of these the piece of
crap do everything I really do want it
but I'm not gonna steal the clock
gannets I can't wait because you don't
want nine lives okay baby
I was hoping for it kids sorry but did I
call that or did I tell ya that was a
really a person everyone knows it's not
doesn't smell good actually it smells
weird you know what exactly ten dollars
exactly - smells like Hollywood basement
I bought it because I like this
particular smell so I wanted to of
course bring up one of my favorite
episodes of the office which is when
Dwight dressed up as the Belsnickel from
Pennsylvania Dutch this is like a nasty
dirty Santa Claus and just a fun little
tradition that the shirts have do you
guys have any weird holiday traditions
my family does this thing where we don't
like really think about gifts that we're
gonna give each other we put it all in
an excel sheet what we want for
Christmas and then we organize who's
gonna purchase it for the other person
and then we don't open our gifts on
Christmas if you open it I'm on
Christmas Eve because we don't want to
wait
your family of murders yes we compete
like various every year we come up with
a different competition for like five
years tree we did a competitions like I
am getting here we did a competition we
were like doing gift-giving competition
I think now recently been doing like
cooking competitions with a family
judges so we like to people decided to
cook some and we fit who's better
all right well the closeout this Yankee
Swap I guess oh my god I guess this last
president or I could choose to steal you
can say Jordan you can get a piss
flavored candle has your blood on it
Chris I might steal the candle the
candle so that means you get that one
Chris oh but can't no that means he can
take something - oh you can steal or get
that yeah the only rule is he can't take
the can of act but you can see yeah so
do an Oreo or take that Oh does he do in
that first or no no no
so either you open that or you steal
that's gonna be bad look at this though
I say steal you can steal if you want or
you can open you can steal what you gave
I this is it's like in Magic the
Gathering once you've played a card that
round you tap it this has been tapped
for this round
just made you know what to be honest I
bought that specifically because I knew
I could trade my way into it and he was
virtually it see what you don't want
this so you can use a copy of my book to
hide your cigarettes that's awesome as
they say you gotta use the can do
give me a parliament yeah I like to tell
them fire so I guess this is the end of
another holiday episode of every damn
day remember to take care care of
yourself and your loved ones this
holiday season you can check out our
Twitter show extra damn day on the
comedy central Twitter channel we'll see
you next time it's cool smoking is cool
don't forget kids
[Music]